حسنًا، أريد إحضار الدكتورة تانيا هان،
وهي طبيبة العناية المركزة للأطفال
مع أطباء بلا حدود، نحن
نقدر وقتك اليوم يا
دكتور، شكرًا لك على استضافتي، لذلك
على الرغم من مشكلات التواصل
المرتبطة بغزة، فأنا أفهم أنك
تمكنت من التحدث إلى
زملائك  في مستشفى الشفاء،
المستشفى الرئيسي في غزة، ماذا يقولون
لك عما كانوا يتعاملون معه
في الأيام القليلة الماضية،
نعم، لذا مجرد تصحيح
لأننا لم نتمكن من الاتصال
بأي شخص في مستشفى ألفا لمدة يومين
الآن أه  مثلك ومثل بقية
عالم الإعلام، فقدنا
الاتصال الكامل بـ UM، آخر مرة سمعنا فيها أن
الوضع كان
مروعًا، وذلك قبل
الغزو الفعلي للمستشفى،
كان المستشفى تحت الحصار الكامل
محاطًا بالدبابات العسكرية
والموظفين  لم يتمكنوا من التحرك حتى داخل
المستشفى الذين وصفوا إطلاق النار عليهم من
خلال النوافذ عندما
حاولوا المناورة عبر
ممرات المستشفى قالوا أه
ممرضتين قُتلتا بالرصاص من خلال
النافذة وتم إطلاق النار على العديد من المرضى
أيضًا ووصفوا  يجري أه
تجريده من الطعام نفاد الماء أه
أعتقد أن الكلمات بالضبط كانت الناس
يصرخون من العطش أه
لم يكن لديهم أه إمكانية الوصول إلى الماء أيضًا ومن
الواضح أن الطاقم الطبي
وصفهم بأنهم قلقون للغاية على
مرضاهم أه وحدة العناية المركزة
المرضى أه لسوء الحظ لم يعد بإمكانهم
تلقي الأكسجين عندما تم
قطع إمدادات الأكسجين، وهذا يشمل كلا من
الأطفال البالغين والأطفال حديثي الولادة أه
حديثي الولادة لم يتمكنوا من الحفاظ على
معدات دعم الحياة، وكان
المرضى الذين يخضعون لغسيل الكلى يطبقون نفس الشيء هناك
وكانوا قلقين للغاية و
كانوا يستجدون
المجتمع الدولي لمساعدتهم في إجلاء
المرضى وتوفير
الأمان بشكل ملحوظ لمرضاهم حتى
الآن في في في أكثر الأوقات ترويعًا
الموضوع المتكرر هو أه
رغبتهم والتزامهم بحماية
المرضى كما وصفوها أه جدًا جدًا
مشاهد مروعة لأكثر من
مائة جثة
لم يتمكنوا من دفنها، لقد حفروا مقبرة جماعية واحدة
قيل لي ودفنوا 80
شخصًا هناك وبقية
الجثث حاولوا الوصول إلى
باري لكنهم في أي وقت  حاولوا
الوصول إليهم وصفوا
استهدافهم وإطلاق النار عليهم أه
وصفوا أيضًا وجود جرحى في
محيط المستشفى لم يتمكنوا من
الوصول إليهم لأن
سيارات الإسعاف لم تكن تستطيع القدوم والذهاب دون
استهداف أه لذلك كانوا على ما أعتقد
بعض الكلمات التي سمعناها كانت آه،
كانوا غير قادرين على توضيح ما يرونه،
وكانوا عاجزين عن الكلام بأن هذه
آه مشاهد لا يستطيع ولا ينبغي لأي مخلوق أن
يتحملها وأه نعم مثيرة للقلق للغاية
وأعتقد أن الأمر الأكثر إثارة للقلق هو
حقيقة أننا  لم يعد بإمكاننا الاتصال بهم
بعد الآن، ولا يمكننا أن نشهد على ما
يحدث وهذا
مبدأ أساسي للمنظمة التي
أعمل بها، وهو
مفهوم الشهادة على هذه
الفظائع والتخفيف من
المعاناة المرتبطة بها